we tend to think that numbers are a
universal language like that if there
was a extraterrestrial signal that hit
earth that it would start with one plus
one his Tim and it would work up from
there and work up from there work of men
and then eventually we're building a
machine that opens a wormhole to Vega
and that's a really good idea for formal
mathematics and formal logic we might
work but the way that humans actually
use numbers can we talk to each other it
is not nearly as universal as you might
think I mean I should say I'm a linguist
not a mathematician I've kind of moved
over to numberphile briefly here but my
background is linguistics and the number
of ways that humans use numbers the
number of ways that humans use numbers
doesn't even make sense you might say
okay there's there's some weird examples
but English is base 10 but it's not
entirely because we still have dozen
which is base 12 we still have grouse
which is 12 times 12 which 144 that's
all base 12 that's do decimal we still
have score in the language we start for
score in seven years ago which was
Abraham Lincoln he meant eighty-seven
but four score and seven resonates
because we used to have base 20 counting
we used to have the decimal and that
still resonates well in the language
today so we still have all of that I
looked up specifically one linguist
called Glendon lean who spent 20 years
touring round Papua New Guinea
Oceania all kind of south eastern areas
he found languages that were base six he
found language that were base 15 he
found all sorts of outliers that you
would find if you have isolated
populations on isolated islands they're
not that weird though I mean you've done
a French video before right you have
Caliban set which is four twenties and
seven that's that's strange before you
you know you can get outside Europe
Hindi Hindi is so irregular that for the
numbers 1 to 100 you essentially have a
hundred different words there is a
pattern in there behind them but the
forms are so irregular and they change
so much new basically have to learn a
hundred different words Danish Danish is
an astonishing one the Danish number 458
is I'm totally not going to pronounce
this correctly although he'll trace I
think I apologize to the people of
Denmark Oda
is eight that's easy I think we always
in there as well ignore the G that's
just to link things together and then
you've got this which is held rice half
third I know that's that's meant to mean
fifty so what's going on there so that
is an abbreviation that is hell thrice
and toover again I'm sorry but that is
half the rice times 20 which still
doesn't make any sense because how can
you manage half times three terms right
how does that make 50 well they get
another catch because this bit here half
thrice is like Roman numerals what
you've got there is half away from
thrice so this literally means 3-4 half
times 20 which if you actually do the
math on it's two and a half times 20
which is 50 so you finally have 58 you
have half thrice two and a half times 20
plus 858 so the complete opposite end of
the scale is tongan which is wonderful
um there are there are a few more formal
ways you can say those but essentially
if you are saying a really complicated
number like seven hundred and seventy
one thousand two hundred and sixteen you
say the numbers 4 7 7 1 2 1 6 in order
that's it it is as simple as that you
just say the numbers one thing I suspect
most of your viewers will think is that
at least we've agreed on Arabic numerals
now at least we've got the standard 5 6
7 8
stem 0 to 9 that everyone uses ah not
quite some languages are particularly
those in India and China still use their
own numeral system particularly formal
things like we still use Roman numerals
for clock faces they might use them in
similar places Super Bowl and Super Bowl
of course yes although Super Bowl 50 is
going to be Super Bowl 55 0 because
Super Bowl L doesn't really sound all
that impressive there's a few other
obvious points mainland Europe uses a
comma for the decimal point and a
full-stop to separate thousands you can
us or the other way around if you're
using currency then there are a whole
load of different ways to say and no
sense you might put a slash you might
put a comma and a slash you might put
double O and then there's the big one
because I said thousands separator a
while ago and that's not Universal
either and I really got surprised by
this when I looked up there is not a
universal thing for how many digits
should be in each group if you go to
South Asia to India to Pakistan to areas
around there you will find they don't
use I mean they do they can use that as
well but frequently the system that is
used is the crore and the lakh watch
your British guy try and explain crore
and lock your lakh is 10 to the 5 and
your crore is 10 to the 7 and here's the
thing they are written like this your
least significant group is 3 digits and
each group that's more significant than
that is 2 so you can have a lakh crore
which is going to be 10 to the 12 and
watch me mess this up that's 5 7 that's
9
that's 11 which is going to be written
like that that's a trillion and there's
no reason why that should be a trillion
instead of a lakh crore it's just what
we happen to decide you might be able to
argue that constant threes is maybe a
bit more understandable but that's
coming from a really English perspective
I would be absolutely certain that
someone who grew up with this system
would have just as good a reason why
theirs is more logical
let's say all written spoken language
fails let's say you have someone who you
have absolutely nothing in common with
at all at least you can gesture at least
you can say you know 8 & 9 3 there no no
no um I I even thought that was
universal until someone I know came back
from China and told me that if you are
going to be in certain regions in China
you are going to be using hand
is that a completely different so you
get one two three four five I'm going to
try this I know somewhere in the
comments is going to call me out to my
hand position seemed a little long but
it is roughly six seven eight nine ten
or sometimes ten which are based on the
shapes of the original Chinese
characters for those numbers that kind
of blew me away but then I found the
paper from Glendon Leena I mentioned
right at the start about Papua New
Guinean languages in that area who use a
brilliant thing called a body count
tally system so they will go one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
and then depending on which language it
will follow different points around the
face or it might might go across and
down the other side okay there are a lot
of differences between languages but the
majority who use that system base twenty
seven because you have twenty seven
points that they refer to to keep tally
and we're not going to be doing advanced
calculus in this we're going to be you
know doing everyday conversations but
that means you can do things like one
man and here thirty seven um you can
start keeping tally with exact and
that's wonderful because that is
something that I hadn't even thought of
I haven't even come up with before
reading about it that wasn't something
that my my mind was open to what I
wanted to do to have it kind of the
grand finale was to look at what science
fiction writers had done with alien
languages but then now we're even close
to that
I looked up Klingon I love Klingon from
Star Trek Klingon is base-10 with words
four thousand and million it's clearly
written by an English speaker and it's
more English and more more normal for us
for those with over here than the half
the languages I've talked about and it's
meant to be an alien species I know in
Star Trek they're all meant to have come
from a common ancestor blood we did come
from a common ancestor and we've got
much much weirder numbers in our own
human speech than science fiction has
ever come up with I think that's one of
the best things about
linguistics about being human about all
of this is that someone on the other
side of the world something that they
will consider absolutely normal can
completely blow your mind we'd like to
thank Squarespace for supporting this
video if you want a simple powerful and
beautiful website then check them out
ru Squarespace myself my blog and I can
tell you I'm a really happy customer but
if you're a bit more advanced than me I
want to really fine-tune all aspects of
your site then Squarespace is developer
tools really let you get under the hood
and tinker with everything so if you've
got a great idea for a website online
store podcast or anything else that
needs a web presence check them out you
can even give it a trial run set up a
site see what you think with no credit
card required and then if you do sign on
for a year they'll throw in a free
domain name use the offer code
numberphile and you'll get 10% off your
first purchase so go to Squarespace comm
slash numberphile remember that offer
code great stuff and thank you to
Squarespace for supporting numberphile